[? LAURIE: ?]
Hello, and welcome.
We are really pleased
to be able to
introduce John Paul Caponigro.
He's more than just a talented
photographer.
He is a gifted visual artist.
He shares his vision and
creativity through his images.
And you'll be seeing
that today.
He does lectures, seminars, and
workshops as well as writing.
And today, he'll share his
creative process and inspire
you in this journey
of discovery.
And one of my favorite quotes
of JP's is, "How the artist
gets there is, perhaps, just
as important as how they
arrive." JP is a member of the
Photoshop Hall of Fame.
He's a Canon Explorer
of Light.
And he's a contributing editor
to photographic magazines and
a sought after lecturer
around the world.
So we're pleased to be able
to present our series of
photographers at Google, Mr.
John Paul Caponigro.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN PAUL CAPONIGRO: Thank
you, [? Laurie ?].
And thank you, Google.
Thank you guys for
coming today.
And thanks for helping build
something I use every day.
It's a different world as a
result of what you guys are
doing, and it's pretty cool.
I wanted to talk
today briefly--
maybe, a little too
briefly, we'll
just scratch the surface--
about the creative process.
There's a lot of pixel peeping
that goes on in the industry
of digital photography.
And, in many ways, those
subjects can be the easier
things to discuss.
Sometimes, maybe we don't talk
about the creative process,
how we got where we got, where
we started, why we ended up
where we ended up.
Those are, sometimes, a
lot harder to discuss.
And in part, I think
that's because it's
a process of discovery.
Particularly as artists, we
don't always know what our end
result is until we
get started.
But somewhere along the way,
we start to get clues, like
solving a mystery.
We find pieces that start
to fit together.
And we do get into certain
creative modes and perform
certain creative operations that
are repeatable, can be
consistent, that we can share
with other people.
And those are the kinds of
things I want to discuss
somewhat today.
One definition of creativity--
and I know that there are a
lot of them.
You can find a whole collection
of quotes on
creativity on my website.
I collect quotes.
And I put 'em out on my social
networks including, Google+--
is to create a shift in
perspective, to see things in
a new light.
And one of the things that I
wanted to do is share some of
the stories behind a few of my
images, both as a visual
introduction to the kinds of
things that I do and as a way
of sharing how being engaged
in a creative process--
and I really like to talk about
it as creative process,
not necessarily engaged in
photography, not necessarily
engaged in drawing, not
necessarily engaged in writing
or any of the other creative
operations, modes, media, that
I use synthetically,
holistically in my process--
when you engage in that,
your perception shifts.
We do this in part to understand
the world a little
better and also to understand
what's inside of us, which is
often one of the hardest things
to bring to light and
one of the reasons that
I make the types of
images that I make.
Robert Frost said something
that I think is wonderful.
No surprise to the writer, no
surprise to the reader.
So I think that process of
discovery has to start here
with each of us in a creative
process, so we have to be
creative with our process, and
that each one of our processes
will change over time.
And then, each one of
ours is unique.
There's a different state
or a different flow
at different times.
So I want to share some of the
stories that have changed the
way that I think about making
images and think about
photography, or just
images in general.
One of the reasons I got
involved with photography is
that photography can
show us so much.
And I think one of the best
things about photography is
that it can record
so much detail.
And one of the worst things
about photography is that it
can record so much detail.
And the big question then is,
is what's inside the frame
significant detail?
Secondarily, how do we know?
One of the things that
attracts me most to
photography is that
it can freeze a
fast-moving moment like this.
I can sense these complex
relationships
dimly, perhaps diffusely.
But they're moving too fast for
me to really consider them
at length and to compare them
to patterns before and after
and how they change.
There's something about the
still image, being able to
freeze really complex
relationships, that's really
quite fascinating.
You could look at Eadweard
Muybridge's work and how it
changed the way that we think
about time and motion, how it
answered the debate of whether
a horse's hoofs are all off
the ground as it runs.
One interesting question
becomes, at what point do we
stop verifying our own
perception and rely on the
documents, the objects that we
create, as a way of deciding
what's real or truthful.
We're in this very interesting
time, where we're becoming
increasingly cybernetic.
And we're deferring that notion
of the eyewitness to
the tools that we use.
And we have to be careful about
that, because we're
deeply involved in the creation
of the tools, the
objectives, how they're used.
Objectively only happens
by degrees.
What you know changes
what you see.
What you see changes
what you know.
The French psychologist Piaget
really tells us about this
whole process.
And I think it's one of the
reasons why a visual creative
discipline is so important.
Because the more you can
see, the more you know.
And the more you can see
in many ways, well, you
can see even more.
I find it fascinating that
a viewer's knowledge base
changes the questions
that they ask.
And I think is so important
ask questions.
Photographers will often come up
to me, look at this image,
and ask how did you
get that exposure?
There's very little light.
I know that that long exposure,
the light on the
water, should have blurred
to this mist.
How'd you get that?
I said, well, I took a clue from
Steven Spielberg, and I
exposed by day and color
adjusted to make
it look like night.
Oh, you cheated.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN PAUL CAPONIGRO: And it's a
funny statement, because we
really have to ask, whose
game are we playing?
I mean, there are rules
to the game.
But there are many
different rules.
One of the challenges in
photography is we have only
one word for photography.
Now, are we talking about Jerry
Uelsmann's surrealism,
or are we talking about James
Nachtwey's frontline
documentary?
We expect very different
practices as a result.
But we have one word
for them both.
And that, to me, seems
woefully lacking.
We need to update our whole
concept so that we can
communicate more clearly.
Look at what writers Can you
imagine having one word for
writing a screenplay,
fiction, poetry?
Well, how about just fiction
and nonfiction?
It's a lot more elegant than
photograph and photo
illustration.
What kind of photo
illustration?
For medical and forensics,
or for--
you see where I'm going.
We need to update
our language.
Astronomers ask me entirely
different questions.
They say, where did you find
that constellation?
I don't recognize it.
I said, yes, you're right.
I painted it in Photoshop to
make it look more like my eye
sees and less like the hard
colored points that sometimes
streak in the camera.
So based on their knowledge
base, they're looking at it
totally differently and making
different assumptions, and
bringing something different
to the game.
And I think we have to
understand that our viewers
are always bringing something
to the game of looking.
And it as a game.
There are rules.
There's a context.
But also, it's fun.
It's really interesting.
It's like solving a mystery.
We all see different things.
One of the reasons this is my
favorite image, probably, is
not only because it started a
whole new relationship with
one of my, well, formal
obsessions to symmetry.
It's been a great device to
suggest that other things have
a life and a spirit but also
because it highlights this
process of the viewer's
involvement, and it enriches
my understanding
of my own work.
One evening in a gallery, a
gentleman reeking of Scotch
and smoke came up to
me and said, I love
your satanic icon.
And I'm looking around
the room.
And he leads me to this.
And I kept asking him
what he was up to.
But I didn't share my original
thoughts or what I was
thinking at the time, because
it changes over time.
It gets more complex.
It grows.
Because I thought he was
sufficiently inebriated that,
well, I have this deal that if
I share what I share, I first
get the other person to
share what they felt.
And I don't want my
interpretation to supplant theirs.
I just want the two,
the exchange, to
enrich the whole thing.
A good friend of mine bought
this image, brought
it home to his wife.
Look, isn't it beautiful?
Where should we hang it?
You're not hanging
that in here.
Why not?
It's dirty.
What do you mean, It's dirty?
It's an x-ray of somebody
sitting on a toilet.
Can't you see?
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN PAUL CAPONIGRO:
Just keep going.
One of the other things that
I got and one of the best
compliments of my career from
a four-year-old, who crossed
the threshold and stopped,
held his breath.
I said, OK, I don't care
how often it sells.
I don't care where it
gets collected.
If you can catch the breath of
a four-year-old, success.
And then, the arms go flying.
And he starts sputtering.
It was the first time I really
was happy there was glass in
front of my prints.
And he says, it's, it's,
it's a giant sneeze.
And I'm sitting over in the
corner of the gallery,
watching this whole process,
thinking, I titled it Avra,
which is the Sanskrit
word for breath.
Breath, sneeze, close enough.
And it's interesting to ask just
how specifically we want
to communicate our intention and
how often it gets looser
and, yet, there still
is a common
connection, a common thread.
And I think we want
to look for that.
Sometimes the stories that other
people have shared about
my images changed my
reaction to them.
And I'm sure that it happens
between each other.
I'll just share one of
the mysteries here.
This image is profoundly
challenging to me.
Because the first time I
exhibited it, four women, over
the space of a weekend, came and
shared stories in front of
it about losing a significant
male figure, a
son, a father, a lover.
The strange thing is this
happened more than two dozen
times over the past 15 years.
I can't explain it.
I can sweep it into that dustbin
called coincidence.
But I think it has something
more to do with Jung's idea of
synchronicity.
There's something happening in
front of that, and I don't
know what that is.
In fact, I'm trying to figure it
out and explore it a little
more deeply and wondering, how
can I get into that territory
where something more universal
is shared?
And how can I do work that's
a little bit beyond me?
Because that's where the areas
of greatest growth are.
I think sometimes not knowing
is actually a benefit.
I remember being in another
gallery show, doing the
preview with the gallery
director.
He wanted to be able to
tell stories about the
images over the month.
And I was only there
for that weekend.
And I came in front
of this image.
And I couldn't remember whether
I'd captured the snow
or whether I'd rendered
it with Photoshop.
And it got me to look at
the image more closely.
It got me to go and look
at other photographs
of snow more closely.
And it got me to go and look
at snow more closely.
For not knowing, I became
richer, because I'd looked
more carefully.
And I think that photography can
offer many opportunities
for that if we'll only
accept an invitation.
So there's one thing to stay up
in this visual experience.
And a lot of times, that remains
intuitive and vague.
It's very often useful to follow
it and put this into
words, even if the words are
just getting things going, to
have some sense of clarity of
what happened, or what we're
trying to accomplish, or
what I might do next.
The first time I went to White
Sands to photograph seriously,
I spent an evening
and a morning,
shot 24 rolls of film.
Yeah, this was back
in the film days.
I came way with two keepers.
I thought, OK, two
keepers, not bad.
I mean, now many images do you
really make that are really
worth sharing, at least
in a gallery context.
About 1% is what most of
my colleagues and I
have kind of agreed.
And that doesn't mean you get to
take your camera and put it
on motor drive and
hope that one--
kind of the spray and
pray phenomena--
doesn't work as well as being
a little more considered
looking at your first shot,
figuring out how to improve
it, looking at the successes
and then how to do other
successes that might build on
those successes and even get
out of certain grooves or
out of certain ruts
and into a new groove.
It's useful to be a little
more considered.
But I hadn't really figured out
why I liked this image.
I hung it.
It wasn't quite as surreal
as some of the impossible
symmetries or floating stones
that I'm known for.
It helped a lot--
well, it felt good-- when my
father came in and patted me
on the back one morning.
Because I had put in my dining
room, spent some time with it.
I think it's really useful to
spend time with your images,
one of the great things
about prints.
It's one thing to have
them in hard drives.
It's one thing to have them
up on social networks.
But how often do we consider
them casually, for a sustained
time, a little more officially,
like over time?
You think a lot about how you
interact with your images.
So Dad came in and said,
that's a good one kid.
You managed to avoid all
the West Coast cliches.
I went, that feels good.
That's great.
But I still hadn't found
what I was looking for.
Until my father-in-law, an
engineer, came in and squinted
and said, is that water?
Got it.
I'm not photographing
grains of sand.
I'm photographing waves.
Now, I had to take his water
and turn it into my wave,
important to personalize
the language.
But once I did that, I went
back to the same scene,
photographed for the same amount
of time, then came up
with a dozen keepers.
Because I was focused
along lines that
were relevant to me.
And I had found a theme that
worked through almost all of
my work, the idea of waves.
These were just slower-moving
waves.
Ironically, after that long,
hot walk, I took shelter in
the shade of the park sign and
started reading the literature
for the first time.
These dunes move three
feet a month.
It was there in front of
me all along, you know.
And sometimes, I think
artists get into--
and we all get into--
modes where we sense things
intuitively, where we put a
lot of information together,
both things that we have
sensed mentally, physically,
the other
things that we've read.
We aggregate a lot
of information.
And it comes out in the
things that we do.
And it's one of the reasons I
think it's so important not
just to think it but
also to do it.
Because there's another kind
of understanding that comes
from actually making
something.
There are a lot of other stories
up on my website.
I want to shift gears here and
talk about, in this case, how
tools can change perception.
There's an awful lot of dialogue
out there about the
latest megapixel count or how
many picoliters come off a
printer, or what kind of
fancy routines you can
do with your software.
It's fun.
I mean, we live in
an amazing time.
More change to this medium of
photography in the last 10
years than in its 175-year
history.
I remember years ago-- this
was about 15 years ago--
an analogy in Macworld.
If you took the Rolls-Royce
and the personal computer,
gave the same decrease in price
and the same increase in
performance, the Rolls-Royce
would go seven times the speed
of sound and cost $0.70.
Of course, that's 15 years out
of date, so I have absolutely
no idea what the new math is.
Very interesting.
Have our ideas about what
photography is, how we can
practice it, not
how we should--
remember, there's
no cheating--
in the arts or in anything,
really.
It's really just a matter
of misrepresentation.
If I put one of my surreal
composites in Time magazine,
I'm misrepresenting that it is
that kind of photograph and
belongs in that kind
of context.
There's nothing cheating
about it.
I think we need to just do the
work we need to do and then
start to make some interesting
statements about what happened
and decide, well, what kind of
photography is it and what
uses can I put it to?
But none of this limiting,
thou shalt not.
Who wrote those commandments?
Who gave them the right?
We need to all give ourselves
the right to rewrite that
playbook and play our own games,
the games that will
help us get where we want to go
in our own authentic ways.
So it's great to have the
training, not only of a
painter, but also of
a photographer.
My dad's a well known fine
art photographer.
And he taught me what I know
about black and white
photography.
My mother also taught me
about offset printing.
And it was a great
combination.
Because ink jet, digital
cameras, it all came together.
Plus, the compositing,
some of the painting.
She used to be a painter,
as well.
So it was a good marriage of
all of that knowledge base.
But I still have to overcome
my curse of expertise.
I've been trained to do certain
kinds of things in
certain routines.
And I've been trained to
think in certain ways.
And one of the biggest
challenges for me is to
rethink what I'm doing, how
I'm doing it, based on new
possibilities.
And with this blistering pace of
change, we need to do this
now more than ever.
There are some pretty
wonderful, wonderful
opportunities.
So one of the big issues in
photography is learning how to
think within the frame,
how to compose, those
four essential lines.
The four most important lines
are the border, what's in,
what's out, what visual
dynamics you create.
What's the aspect ratio or
proportion of that frame?
But now, with stitching, we
also need to learn how to
think outside the frame.
And it might not be creating a
panoramic format like this.
Sometimes, it's just a matter
of that extra inch, a little
the left, a little to
the right, a little
up, a little down.
And I constantly have
to catch myself and
develop a new habit.
If I find that I'm eliminating,
I would say, oh,
that's the old sacrifice
I used to have to make.
And I'd just pull up or pull
over to get the information.
At the end of the day, all we
really need to do is quote
Pee-wee Herman and say,
I meant to do that.
That's what my artistic
intention was, like all of
those art critics some
of us went through.
What is your intention
young man?
I don't know.
You tell me.
And so it's also useful to
remember these panoramic
formats are both vertical
and horizontal.
Or if you're David Hockney,
they're all over the place--
a pretty interesting way of
representing what to us is a
very dynamic, fluid--
first alarm.
I knew this was going
to be fast--
a very dynamic, fluid
process of looking.
Now, how do we represent
that in a still frame?
So I'm not going to go through
the Photoshop routine of just
merging those two.
It's fairly simple.
Just to remind you, and remind
myself, that there are
multiple ways to merge it.
And the way that I go through
it will change different
relationships within
the image.
Now, I have the question,
do I crop or do I clone?
Well, it depends on what
kind of photography
I'm trying to make.
And also, I think, it depends
on whether it's relevant.
If I clone in something like the
top of this sky, it's just
white texture.
Is that really cheating?
Is that really
misrepresentation?
Should that no longer qualify
as documentary?
I'm not sure it's
really relevant.
On the other hand, if I take a
panoramic stitch like this--
and I know certain distortions
are involved in that, and
we'll come back to that
in just a second--
I can then decide, do I
crop, or do I clone?
How much do I crop or clone?
If I decide to crop this much,
because I want to make sure
that's there and I'm left over
with this, am I willing to
clone that out?
If I do something like that--
and it's amazing how fluid
that is today--
so if we do something like
content over a film.
And believe it or not, they've
even got stuff on mobile
platforms these days for this
kind of technology that will
sample other areas.
Now, if somebody is looking at
it from a geologic standpoint
or from cartography, Houston,
we have a problem.
I'm going to get fired
from the "Sun-Times".
Well, maybe not the "Sun-Times"
but "New York
Times."
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN PAUL CAPONIGRO: OK, like,
in my case, though, if I'm
making a fine art print,
is it really relevant?
Does it matter?
Am I willing to aestheticize.
Depends on the type of image
that I'm making.
And often, I'll make multiple
kinds of images presented in
context with one another.
And the clues that I do or don't
do something indicates
what kind of photograph it is.
So what about taking an image
like this and turning it into
an image like that?
Yes, of course, there are
special effects added to that.
But look at the spatial
relationships in that.
Now, lens profiles were designed
to cure the side
effects of lenses,
an interesting
proposition right there.
So the optical system introduces
distortions, which
are OK in journalistic
contexts.
Or it's useful to identify
those in forensic areas.
You need to know what was
involved so you can
interpret the data.
And I think that's the most
important thing, disclosure,
so we can understand what's been
done and how this thing
has been created.
But if I start to do something
like arbitrarily change the
spatial relationships, pulling
the foreground forward,
pushing the background back,
making this feel longer.
It increases the sense of
recession within the image.
It compacts relationships
here.
You can see this kind of
thing in swings and
tilts with view cameras.
Now, this is being able
do it after the fact.
And one of the challenges here
is to be able to think
predictably in the field.
Should I change my
angle of view?
Or shall I change some
of those spatial
relationships in post?
It's got me thinking about
framing in a very different
way than I used to.
And it's calling me to develop
a new habit to explore the
relative proportions, the
spatial relationships between
objects in the frame, so that I
can make them more powerful,
make them more expressive, fine
tune it, whether subtly
or dramatically.
Sometimes, just using this just
a little bit produces a
lot of change.
But it's a new habit that I
think we all should be aware
that it might benefit many
of us to acquire.
This is not the way that I was
trained to think about
photography.
And we just have to remember,
it's not the same photography
that it was so many years ago.
For instance, will the
real photograph still
please stand up?
OK, so it's a composite.
I guess none of them are
a real photograph.
Now, it's a different
kind of photograph.
OK, so let me rephrase
the question.
See how important phrasing
the question is?
Which Is the original aspect
ratio or the aspect ratio that
I finally landed on?
I think, we'll all agree, that
we have a different visual
response to a horizontal
panorama than we do to
something that's horizontal,
square,
vertical, or vertical panorama.
Now, we could do that
very convincingly.
Let me show you.
So I'm just going to duplicate
the layer here
and transform it.
Child's play, right?
Edit, transform.
We're just going to
distort the frame.
Past a certain point,
you can see things
get obviously distorted.
And if you hadn't seen the
original, would you know that
something like that had
been distorted?
Probably not.
After all, you've been looking
at a slightly distorted
presentation this entire time.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN PAUL CAPONIGRO: But do you
see, there's more than one
way to distort it?
If I came back in here and
used content or a scale
similar to the content or a
fill, is looking at the
smoother areas in the image and
compressing them more--
look at the glacier.
Do you see the relationship
between the mountain and the
edge of the glacier and as that
white, dead space in the
middle gets compacted--
see how much more forceful
the image becomes?
Now, let me distort them to
the same amount, because I
want an apples to apples
comparison here
or oranges to oranges.
So one has been distorted
distorting the sky and the
smooth area of the snow
more than the other.
And you see the different
proportional relationships?
Certain areas have been
distorted more than another.
And of course, if I was willing
to mask, I could
localize that distortion,
as well,
bringing them closer together.
So this gets me thinking about
framing in the field a little
differently.
If I see two objects that are
far apart, either top to
bottom, left to right, I know
I can squeeze 'em in and
intensify that relationship
between two significant things
in my frame, either by changing
my angle of view.
And if there is a wall or a
cliff or a body of water I
don't feel like getting into
after, in post, or both.
See what this does
to your brain?
So that's the most important
thing, what it
does to your brain.
Because you start to see more
possibilities out there.
You start to think
more predictably.
And that's what previsualization
is about,
being aware of what your tools
are capable enough, to be able
to get the material you need to
get the final result you're
looking for.
It doesn't mean there's
not a process of
discovery along the way.
I'm not 100% certain that I want
one form of distortion
over the other.
But I've got enough material
in my original captures to
allow me to explore both
possibilities.
I can get where I want to go.
And that's what we would like
to do, be aware of the
possibilities, photograph more
versatility, make more of this
situation, and be able to
enhance it further to create
results what we stand
behind 100%.
So I routinely play with things
like how the frame is
divided, selectively distorting
the image, fine
tuning the proportion of it.
They're very different
visual statements.
And I often like to play process
of elimination, too
much space, too cramped, still
too much space, still too
cramped, one or the other.
And this process of elimination
helps a lot.
And the other thing that's
really important, to activate
all of your full visual
intelligence, is to use
interfaces that allow you to do
side by side comparisons.
I could look at this thing one
at a time and flip back and
forth between the other.
But I can't make those fast
decisions when you look at
both together.
Contextual seeing is
really important.
It's one of the things
that puzzles me most
about iPads or tablets.
We're back to the
Greek scroll.
What happened to two pages, the
image and text, or the new
book, web page and
text, or a video.
You see where I'm going.
I did.
There's probably a technological
limitation of
putting two touch screens,
you know, how much more
it's going to cost.
But to get away from that, side
by side contextuality is
a huge change in
the interface.
And I think we need to think
a lot about the design of
interfaces.
There was one TED talk that I
thought was brilliant, how it
was saying that in the
1900s, the dominant
model was the novel.
In the 20th century, it
was the movie or film.
And in the 21st century,
it's now the interface.
That's an interesting
statement.
So I start to have to think more
predictably about things
like, well, the basic
building blocks of
photography, time and light.
I missed my top-selling shot,
because I was still thinking
in 125ths of a second the first
time I went to try and
photograph Zabriskie Point
in Death Valley.
A friend of mine shook her
finger at me and said, well,
I'll bet you could do
it differently.
I think she was thinking I
was going to create some
impossible symmetry, composite
something unusual into it.
That's when the light
bulb went off.
And I realized I
had to go back.
It took me a year to get back.
And, well, as I was standing
there, photographing the same
composition over the space of
45 minutes, I was thinking,
oh, no, I'm looking for dramatic
light in every area
of the image.
There's going to be no
shadow, no contrast.
I had to modify my plan
when I finally got
to putting it together.
But I had harvested.
I just held to my original
plan enough to get enough
information in enough shots to
be able to recompose that
lighting situation, which
doesn't exist at
any 125th of a second.
It's sunrise, 45 minutes
later, 20
minutes later after that.
It's asking me to think more
predictably about time and
light, those basic building
blocks of photography.
And it opens up possibilities
like this.
The same shots can be used to
render entirely different
versions of the same subject.
This kind of step being done
routinely in product
photography, a little tougher
in landscape photography.
But if you've got
passing clouds,
they're really your friends.
Full open sunlight, edge of the
clouds, beautiful diffused
light, cloud for shade.
So really, I think, one of the
things I like most about all
of this is the way that
it changes my mindset.
And I think mindset
is everything.
It prepares you for so much.
Like for draftsmen, for a
compositor, to be able to
think about putting pieces
together, makes me think about
shooting fragments.
I remember a friend of mine,
years ago, railing, you
digital photographers,
you can't take a
whole photograph anymore.
Everything is pieces.
So I had to figure out what I
wanted to do with this and
photograph a stone from half a
dozen angles, all with the
right lighting, to be able to
get it to fit together.
And I had to think about how
light would create shadows,
would get distorted across the
surface so they'd be harder
closer to the objects, softer
further away, and that they do
contain color.
They're not just black.
What was interesting is, just
like people who write really
great fiction novels spend a lot
of time observing reality
and making a lot of notes,
compositors, draftsmen,
painters have to spend a lot
of time looking at the
richness of life in order
to recreate it.
And a lot of times, this 125th
of a second fast seeing
doesn't get you to slow down and
consider things a little
more carefully.
And when you bump into having
to do something like this
credibly, the more you start
to get sensitive to that
stuff, the more credible
your fictions become.
A lot of fun to think about
just how you want to
recompose an image.
It's so much fun to cheat.
I mean, play.
And, really, I do want to
celebrate that playful spirit,
because it's in that play that
a lot of discoveries happen.
It's also, you know, a little
bit of ingenuity.
You go to the racetrack
in Death Valley.
It's too wet to get out to those
rocks that slide around
and leave those mysterious
tracks.
So you take the shots.
And you clone out the cracks
and make your own tracks.
Oh, you cheated.
No, I invented.
And it's also very interesting
to ask, how many ways can you
remove something from a
photograph and significantly
change the statement and/or
bring something new to it?
Interesting to think about
bowls and paths.
It's their emptiness
that creates their
utility, you know?
A room is useful because it has
space that can be used.
When does the elimination
of something
create something new?
When is less more?
So there's a whole new visual
strategy here, just by
rethinking the game.
And sometimes, you're forced,
in these situations, to come
up with new ideas, that you
hadn't anticipated getting to.
And you probably have so many
ideas, you need to have a
sketch book to write all of
these things down, or a
notepad, something on your
iPhone or your cell phone or
anything to catch these ideas.
The human mind can really only
hold about seven things.
Unless you're Glenn Gould.
And then, you can probably
hold about 5 or
10 melodies at once.
But he's unusual.
Usually, we can only hold about
seven things at any one
given time.
And we need some
way to offload.
See?
We need some way to offload that
information and free our
mind, our processing power,
up to do new tasks.
So how we do that is just as
important as what we choose to
write down, because it will
shift the way that we think.
I remember coming back from
Antarctica, sitting next to my
friend Arthur Meyerson.
He was watching me sketch on my
iPad as I was working on a
composition, so I
was thinking.
He leaned over me and said,
JP, your process is so
different than the
rest of ours.
I said, well, it's not that
different from painters.
You just need to hang out with
a few more painters, Arthur.
But here was a friend who had
known me for 20 years.
And he was still surprised by
how I was working things out
and developing things.
And I felt OK, it was time
to bring that forward.
So I put together an exhibit,
a Blurred Book to create a
catalog for it, and now, just
recently released an e-book on
my creative process, many of
the things that go into it.
And there's a whole section on
drawing, on composition, on
color, and even cell phone
photography as a way of
playing, exploring ideas.
One of the things that I want
to emphasize is that very
often we suffer from a
curse of expectations
that are too high.
Let me ask you guys
a question.
How many of you can draw?
OK, so I got 10% of the crowd?
Let me ask you another
question.
What happened?
I don't know how many of you
have read this book.
David Bayles and Ted Orland has
this wonderful book called
"Art & Fear." And in it, they
relate the story of a
colleague driving his daughter
home from school after class.
She asks, so, Dad, what
did you do today?
Well, I taught my students
how to draw.
When did they forget?
It's wonderful.
Can you imagine a
kid not drawing?
It doesn't happen very often.
And, in fact, when I go and ask
kindergartners and grade
school students, particularly
the younger they are, we get
an 80%, 90% response.
And as they get older, sometime
between the ages of 8
and 13 or 14, they start getting
more self-conscious--
fewer hands go up--
to the point where
we get this adult
syndrome of I can't draw.
Maybe, I didn't phrase the
question well enough.
I didn't ask you, how many
of you can draw like
Michelangelo.
So maybe that's not your goal.
It takes a lot of training.
It takes a lot of time.
I can draw like this, but I
don't get the time to put 40
hours or 30 hours into a
drawing, or even the 20 hours
it takes to do something
like this.
I often don't find it's really
that useful to put the one
hour that it takes to do
something like this, 1 hour to
20 minutes.
More often than not, I'm just
sketching on my iPad,
sketching ideas down, knocking
'em out in less than a minute.
It was a tiny little sketch
that Edison handed his
development team for
the phonograph.
It was this crawly little doodle
that he said, here
we're going to make this,
the phonograph.
Think how much that changed.
It wasn't a 40-page treatise.
And it didn't exist yet.
So how do you get ideas across
that don't exist?
Drawing is a form of ideation.
And there are many
ways to draw.
And we don't have
to look for--
what are we even going
to call it--
sophisticated ways of drawing?
I wouldn't even say that.
Because I think you can do line
drawings that are very
sophisticated, very simple
things that have very
sophisticated thought patterns
behind them.
We don't have to look for
finished results, if that's
not what we're ultimately
going to produce.
But it can very definitely
help enhance any of our
creative efforts.
I know that it does for me.
When I go into a situation, I
often take inventory of an
environment.
So I'm in Antarctica
for the first time.
It's a completely surreal,
unusual environment.
And I'm taking stock.
I've got moon.
I've got sun.
I've got clouds.
I don't have any stars, because
it's not dark enough.
I've got mountains.
I've got iceberg.
I've got ocean.
How many other components?
I might have an island.
So I draw 'em out.
Not the specific ones,
but I draw a moon.
It's a cloud, a mountain,
an iceberg.
Look, I'm just drawing icons
that I can then reshuffle.
And what if I got
'em all aligned?
What if they were nestled, that
sense of being together,
or cradled, scattered?
I'm still looking for
this one, the
reflection of a mountain.
Antarctica, being the windiest
continent, it's hard to get
smooth reflections.
Maybe I'll have to
composite this.
But what I didn't realize
when I was down
there the first time--
I ended up doing an editorial
body of work, and it doesn't
fit neatly into that
body of work--
I've had to reposition it into
a separate body of work.
And along the way, other ideas
have come to light.
The interesting thing is, when
you draw out the combinations,
you're more likely
to see them.
So these are some of the images
that were produced
along the way.
They're not the specific
compositions, but they're the
same kinds of patterns.
You know how you rent or you buy
a red car and, suddenly,
everybody's driving red cars.
You're sensitizing yourself
to patterns.
And you can use the power of
self-suggestion to be more
aware of certain kinds of
patterns and tell your
subconscious that certain
patterns are more important.
And there are a lot of ways
of dealing with different
operations, which can help not
only when you're compositing
but also when you're
out in the field.
How many significant variations
can I find on the
theme of a tiny little mountain
at the bottom of the
frame and a big sky?
Apparently, there are
a lot of variations.
And I continue to
look for more.
Now, this has become part
of my repertoire.
It's a pattern that I'm
constantly looking for.
We all develop a familiarity
with
certain kinds of patterns.
It's kind of our groove.
Because we can see them
very quickly.
And we can get more successful
images that way.
We start to understand
'em better.
We learn how to make
those stronger.
We practice.
Practice makes better.
Forget about perfect.
And some patterns won't
come as easily.
But if you can identify
the pattern and
practice, it's easier.
Strange thing.
If you write something down,
you're 72% more likely to take
action on it.
So if you sketch something out,
I'm not sure what the
percentage is, but you're far
more likely to recognize that
pattern, to learn
new patterns.
See, it's all about pattern
recognition.
It's about recognizing
the pattern.
And it's also about creating
patterns, as well.
I want to leave on a note that
I think is very important.
It's very hard to be spontaneous
in any arena that
we have a high degree
of expertise in.
To play, to be spontaneous
in that, is challenging.
It's one of the reasons I
love cell photography.
I challenge myself to take on
a number of experiments and
photograph things I normally
wouldn't photograph, things
that don't reinforce my brand.
This is just for play.
I have no idea what I'm
going to use them for.
I'm simply enjoying looking.
But I'm challenging myself
to try and look
in different ways.
This is a selection of
images that all have
this painterly look.
And I'm wondering if it's the
frustrated painter in me
coming out.
Or is it a desire to look more
broadly, to not get hung up on
the details, to have a more
spontaneous quality to it.
I'm not sure.
I'm still figuring that
out as I continue.
I do know that sometimes
they plant the
seeds for other things.
Most the time, it's
just visual play.
It keeps me sharp.
I enjoy it.
It's fun to communicate
with people.
Once in a while, I'll find a
seed that might be worth
developing, a shot that I made
a couple years ago at Point
Lobos with my iPhone.
And I've set something
in motion.
Because I have returned here
this spring and shot with my
DSLR in a very focused way and
was able to be very productive
in three short sessions and
bring a certain kind of
intensity and understanding,
because I'd done some of the
visual research.
I strongly recommend that you
allow yourself to play, not
only to rekindle that creative
process, that spirit.
Because we get involved in
creative lives, because it
reinvigorates us.
It refreshes us in
so many ways.
It not only freshens
our perspective.
It puts energy into
our system.
It keeps our minds stimulated
in interesting ways.
But along the way, we often
discover some things that are
personally relevant, that
are resonant within us.
Sometimes it surprises
us what we discover.
And I think it's important to
give ourselves permission,
make a little space in our
lives, to be a little less
results-oriented, to be a
little more authentic.
We go some places we never
expected to go, because that's
part of the process
of discovery.
I think photography is
just one component in
a process of discovery.
It may be the area that I have
a degree of expertise in.
It might be what I do
professionally.
But I have to watch my curse of
expertise and remind myself
to rekindle that little kid who
could draw, that little
kid who could.
Picasso said, it takes a long
time to grow young.
I don't think so.
We were kids once.
We could all draw.
We were all spontaneous.
You ever met a kid who's
not creative?
You ever met a kid who doesn't
ruthlessly, mercilessly push
the envelope?
Hey, Dad, you know that rule
that you said yesterday?
Does that still apply today?
Let me test that.
They reconfirm, right?
They're natural-born scientists,
you know.
Theory, test, reconfirm,
all right?
Endlessly inquisitive.
And, I think, if we can rekindle
that spirit and allow
ourselves to move into modes
that are less focused, we
might discover more.
Part of the issue is
being able to get
outside of our box.
The thing that is really neat
is that we can adopt many
different boxes, create boxes
of our own creating, switch
out the box.
I mean, in order to think
outside the box, you first
have a box, right?
But you don't have to play with
one box your entire life.
And you can mix and match.
And it can be very inspiring
to do that.
So I encourage you to engage
in those ideas and allow
yourself a little time to find
out what your photography is,
certainly to be aware of what
the new possibilities are.
Because they're very
expansive.
We have this embarrassment
of riches today.
And rather than doing
everything, I think we have to
make some choices as to what's
most relevant for us.
But a little bit of exposure to
what's possible out there
will help you make better
choices along the way.
And it's certainly stimulating
and a lot of fun.
Thank you for coming today.
And I'd be happy to answer
questions after this.
I wish you good photography
or a visual life.
[APPLAUSE]